en 1847 le navire irlandais le carrix
venait de traverser l'atlantique
il se dirigeait vers québec mais il
s'est échoué lors d'une tempête près de
cap des rosiers en gaspésie selon des
historiens entre 120 et 150 personnes
auraient péri et on aurait retrouvé le
corps de 87 d'entre eux en 2011 les
ossements de trois enfants âgés de 7 à
12 ans ont été découverts sur la plage
de cap des rosiers selon parcs canada
puis en 2016 lors de fouilles
archéologiques
les ossements de 18 autres personnes ont
été retrouvés à ce moment parcs canada
décide de pousser l'enquète plus loin et
eu des analyses qui ont été conduits par
le laboratoire de bio archéologie de
l'université de montréal qui ne sont
permis de confirmer l'hypothèse lequel
les ossements retrouvés en 2011 et en
2016 proviennent des naufragés du 4 x
ces squelettes ont renforcé la thèse
d'une fosse commune où les naufragés du
cac rixe aurait été inhumé en fait on
avait toujours l'âge des ossements
conquis cas qui correspondait mais
maintenant avec les techniques qui est
moderne dont est capable d'identifier le
type d'alimentation que les gens
préconisé dans leur jeune âge donc dans
ce que si clairement régime
d'alimentaire basé sur la pomme de terre
donc on sait qu'à l'époque en 1847 lors
d'une étude de cette péripétie le de du
naufrage mme méjean provenaient de
l'irlande se nourrit cette pomme de
terre puis c'était la grande famine à
l'époque
une cérémonie aura lieu cet été les
restes humains découverts seront
enterrés à cet endroit près du monument
des irlandais ici bruno le lien radio
canada ac.a desrosiers